українці здатні чинити опір і навіть
повернути собі землю яка була окупована
після 24 лютого
надайте їм більше зброї чим більше
озброєння буде надано тим швидше
закінчиться війна
Ми не боїмося Росії ми вважаємо що НАТО
є найсильнішим недієздатнішим альянсом
який коли-небудь існував
припинити видачу віз людям які
приїжджають сюди з будь-яких причин
окрім гуманітарних
Навіть якби в Росії було 5-10% людей які
проти війни то вже йшлося аби про
мільйони людей Ви хочете щоб ці мільйони
були всередині Росії чи за її межами
пане ланц бергеться Ласкаво просимо на
Deutsche Welle дякую
Я хотів би розпочати з інтерв'ю яке
президент України Володимир Зеленський
дав кілька днів тому і в якому по суті
закликав захід запровадити заборону на
поїздки для всіх росіян щоб вони мовляв
відчули теж що й українці що їхня країна
дійсно перебуває у стані війни Яка ваша
думка щодо його пропозиції
почнімо з того що Литва ухвалила це
Рішення ще доволі рано
і не лише з політичних причин а і з
практичних
Річ у тому що коли почалася війна до
Литви попрямував величезний потік людей
які шукали притулку
від переслідування наприклад із Білорусі
яке почалося вже давно
2020 року
2020-го Минуло вже два роки а також із
Росії з Москви
можливості консульства обмежені це
означає що люди можуть видати лише
обмежену кількість віз
Отже потрібно відповісти на дуже просте
запитання Кому Ви дасте візу першим
сім'ї члена неурядової організації який
може зазнавати переслідувань батько чи
мати якого зазнають переслідувань або
туристу який хоче провести кілька
прекрасних днів на узбережжі Литви
відповідь очевидна тому ми практично
припинили видачу віз людям які їдуть на
відпочинок та надаємо лише візи з
гуманітарних міркувань Отже для нас це
не нова дискусія і ми вважаємо що це має
бути загальноєвропейським рішенням тому
що як ви знаєте поки Шенген працює так
як зараз наші кордони пропускають людей
як Губка дехто в'їжджає в одну країну
так якщо Фінляндія видає візу то потім
із нею можна поїхати до ЄС куди завгодно
так так Саме так І ми також бачили такі
випа люди які не мали перебувати в Литві
раптом опиняються тут чи в інших країнах
тож таке трапляється тому ми повністю
підтримуємо рішення на Європейському
рівні є звісно політичний бік питання А
є моральний знаєте коли ми розуміємо що
люди були змушені тікати з України деякі
з них залишаються там борються за своє
життя борються за свої оселі тоді як
люди з країни яка веде війну все що
можуть вільно подорожувати та
користуватися усіма вигадами вільного
світу проти яких по суті бореться їхній
уряд
Але російська опозиція принаймні її
частина
каже що ці візові заборони заважають
людям поїхати до ЄС у безпеку заважають
представникам неурядових організацій
політичним активістам яким зараз у Росії
загрожують тривалі тюремні терміни Таким
чином вони кажуть що по суті виграєте на
руку Путіну
Я б так не сказав Литва є чудовим
прикладом Оскільки ми змогли перестати
видавати туристичні візи і зупинити
людей які приїжджають сюди заради
задоволення
соцмережа але фактично дозволити
приїжджати сюди людям які тікають від
переслідувань знову ж таки я маю на
увазі що ми повинні відповісти собі на
Інше питання з якою Росією Ми хочемо
мати справу у майбутньому тією у якій
ніби дві країни так би мовити одна
диктаторська люди які вирішили
залишитися там залишаються їм все одно а
решта хто проти війни хто дотримується
демократичних цінностей вони поїхали
щось таке це реальність Ці дві Росії вже
реальність не обов'язково Я б так не
сказав знаєте адже ми говоримо що навіть
якби в Росії було 5-10% людей які проти
війни то вже йшлося аби про мільйони
людей Ви хочете щоб ці мільйони були
всередині Росії чи за її межами Яка ваша
відповідь я як і раніше вірю що зміни
приходять зсередини
якщо Ми віримо що в майбутньому на нас
чекає демократична Росія то її
становлення відбуватиметься з середини
і в основному від 5-7-15 Хто знає
скількох відсотків
але це є тими від них
припустімо ЄС єврокомісія європейська
рада зберуться щоб ухвалити рішення про
єдину візову політику
якою буде остаточна позиція Литви
я би припустив що рішення Литви щодо віз
- це той шлях яким можна піти припинити
видачу віз людям які приїжджають сюди з
будь-яких причин окрім гуманітарних як
можна оцінити причини
ми знайшли спосіб співпрацювати з
неурядовими організаціями та багатьма
іншими партнерами
так ми можемо оцінити У кого є
гуманітарна потреба і він тікає від
переслідувань
А хто по суті хотів би лише вдавати і
просто жити більш простим життям тут у
Литві чи на заході
чи відчуває Литва в цілому загрозу з
боку Росії відверто кажучи чи відчуваєте
ви що сюди просочеться Росія і це
дестабілізує Литву я не маю на увазі
вторгнення
ви кажете про людей які приїдуть сюди
так ні не зараз хоча ми бачимо значно
більше російськомовних на вулиці кафе
ресторанах де завгодно бо як ви знаєте
сюди приїхало дуже багато українців дуже
багато білорусів та дуже багато росіян
[музика]
ми відчуваємо зміни але Незалежно від
того чи відчуваємо ми загрозу чи ні я
думаю що процедура перевірок та аналізу
яку ми маємо нині працює і ми можемо
довіряти цій системі Отже можна сказати
що вона працює як на користь Литви так і
на користь тих людей які шукають
притулку
Литва разом з іншими країнами Балтії від
самого початку упродовж довгого часу
була серед найпереконливіших
прихильників України особливо після 24
лютого коли Київ зіткнувся з новим
витоком путінської агресії Як ви
оцінюєте ситуацію зараз
стан конфлікту Я маю на увазі
гадаю ми були не лише політичними
прихильниками а й прихильниками того про
що уряд Литви говорив із перших днів
конфлікту все вирішується на полі бою
історія - це показує здоровий глузд
показує
У принципі країна повинна мати засоби
щоб захистити себе і дати відсіч агресії
у перші місяці війни тривали дуже
жорсткі дебати чесно Наприклад чи
зможуть українці використати зброю чи не
потрапить вона до рук окупантів і це
були дуже складні дебати які
продовжуються досі але ми бачимо що
українці змогли зробити з отриманим
озброєнням це фактично доводить що якби
його дали Україні раніше ми можливо не
побачили того що спостерігаємо
українці здатні чинити опір і навіть
повернути собі землю яка була окупована
після 24 лютого
тому я дійсно вірю і сподіваюся що це
достатній доказ того що українці є
здібними вмілими та надійними партнерами
коли йдеться про захист кордонів Європи
тому єдине що залишається сказати після
вторгнення це надайте їм більше зброї
чим більше озброєння буде надано тим
швидше закінчиться війна
якщо ви вже згадали зброю
Німеччину часто критикують зокрема і
уряд Литви інших держав Європи а також
деякі люди в США
за те що ФРН робить недостатньо для
постачання зброї в Україну
Ви задоволені допомогою Берліна
я знаєте Не в тому становищі що в
критикувати наших партнерів та союзників
тобто я вважаю що всі роблять те що в
їхніх силах з політичних причин з
виробничих причин немає значення
Литовський уряд зробив свій внесок у
допомогу відповідно до наших можливостей
І це те що я можу сказати
нещодавно було оголошено що Сполучені
Штати працюють над новим пакетом
військової допомоги ще на один мільярд
доларів
але коли ви бачите обсяг допомоги
наданої США і порівнюють його з тим що
було зроблено в Європі
Можна помітити що часи коли Сполучені
Штати були основним постачальником зброї
на європейські Континент після Другої
світової війни або навіть під час Другої
світової війни минуле
євро Європа особливо з поняттями
стратегічної автономії взагалі як
промисловий центр воно здатна виробляти
у бік французів
але це серйозна дискусія серйозна
на часі переосмислення
ми Ясно бачимо Чого бракує щоб Європа
спромоглася зробити Крок уперед і почати
захищати свій власний Континент хоча б
порівнюваними коштами з тими які
виділяють з США тому що зараз ми бачимо
що США набирають темп посилюють дедалі
більше озброєнь які так ефектно
використовуються Україною і ви знаєте
мені хотілося б відчувати більше
гордості за Європу бачити більше
європейської зброї яка постачається в
Україну поряд з американською але на
жаль мабуть у нас досі немає такого
потенціалу про це варто подумати і
невдалекому майбутньому і запропонував
би почати думати про це вже зараз разом
на проблема
знаєте у Вільнюсі та в деяких інших
європейських столицях якщо брати ширше
подібні розмови про те що Європа має
робити більше У декого завжди викликають
Почуття що це може якось підірвати НАТО
якщо почнуться розмови про європейську
стратегічну автономію
Давайте поговоримо про те що очевидно
неможливо підірвати НАТО і чи можна
взагалі змінити Альянс чи замінити його
на щось інше очевидно що це неможливо
хто несе найбільше тягар що стало таким
очевидним на прикладі України
на жаль це не європейський Континент на
даний момент ви знаєте ми можемо зробити
багато коли йдеться про гуманітарну
допомогу ми робимо дуже багато і
Німеччина робить дуже багато коли
йдеться про допомогу та прийом біженців
сотні тисяч українців нині перебувають у
Німеччині
але коли йдеться про жорстку силу яка
фактично протистоїть вторгненню то
головний тут усе ще транс-атлантичний
Союз
Я вважаю що це не останні геополітичне
потрясіння яке ми побачимо у XXI
столітті Я думаю що в майбутньому
стабільність підтримуватиметься
транспортичною єдністю
тому я очікував що Європа відіграватиме
в цьому сильнішу роль зокрема із
військової точки зору
оскільки ви згадали про трансатлантичну
єдність і трансатлантичні відносини
здається що на проміжних виборах у США а
потім можливо і на президентських
виборах 2024 року ми побачимо зростання
ізоляційних настроїв у Сполучених Штатах
пов'язаних з дональдом трампом і його
командою але не лише з ними Чи
побоюєтеся ви за майбутнє
трансатлантичних відносин
вважаю що цей рік показав наскільки
єдність важлива з обох сторін Атлантики
і ви знаєте дискусія була знову ж таки
навіть за минулої адміністрації
вона велася По обидва боки не треба
нагадувати що дискусія щодо стратегічної
автономії відбувалося коли Дональд Трамп
керував білим домом у Вашингтоні але
зараз очевидно що обидві сторони
потребують одна одну щоб підтримувати
інфраструктуру безпеки або архітектуру
цієї частини земної кулі а також у
глобальному масштабі тому я сподіваюся
що всі це почнуть розуміти Відколи я
очолив Литовське нзс у мене було багато
зустрічей у Вашингтоні з людьми з різних
політичних таборів
знаєте напевно одне з головних питань
яке ставили люди та політики з країн
Балтії Вашингтоні чи США
дотримуватиметься і надалі свого курсу
отримав Дуже багато відповідей що курс
буде збережено зараз на спокійні часи і
всіляки може статися
але я все одно сподіваюся що ми всі
побачимо що забезпечує нам безпеку та
стабільність
ви якось сказали що на вашу думку
європейські Союз робить недостатньо для
стримування агресії Путіна чи робить Він
досить зараз на вашу думку
Ну я сказав би що українці зі своїми
ракетними установками роблять найважчу
роботу щоб стримувати Путіна і можливо
подальше вторгнення вочевидь адже він
колись говорив про три дні для взяття
Києва схоже він мав плани піти ще далі І
я вважаю що вони в нього досі є але він
навіть не наблизився до Києва Він навіть
не може захопити всю Східну частину
України
він намагається зберегти у своїх руках
Херсон і тому я сказав би що це загалом
все що дуже Просто насправді
зброя у мілих руках бажання боротися і є
найбільшим фактором стримування
добре зрозуміло
але Що має зробити європейські Союз чи
може він зробити більше крім того що я
зрозумів позицію щодо постачання зброї
що може зробити Євросоюз
Я вважаю що нам час почати думати що
буде після війни з будь-якої точки зору
по-перше геополітика
геополітичний союз - це вже кліше але я
все одно вважаю що це важливо поняття
якими не повинні забувати
геополітичний крок було зроблено а він
дуже важливий надання статусу кандидата
в Україні та Молдові
Я думаю це крок у правильному напрямку
але надалі Ми повинні допомогти країнам
перейти до повного членства в ЄС у
майбутньому а не просто говорити про
відновлення після війни насправді Європа
має бути дуже активною у цьому напрямку
а потім сформулювати дуже чітку
стратегію щодо Росії але навіть не лише
це тому що стратегія Європи щодо Росії
також є сигналом для інших можливих
загарбників
чи порушників глобального порядку
безпеки як демократії демократичні союзи
та особливо геополітичні союзи на кштат
Європейського Союзу реагуватимуть у разі
агресії ви маєте на увазі Китай
погляньмо правді у вічі порушення
відбувається і в дрібніших випадках ми
бачимо багато таких іскор у глобальному
масштабі Я думаю що існує певне
переконання серед багатьох особливо менш
демократичних акторів які кажуть що у
повітрі так багато м'ячів що Європа та
Сполучені Штати не можуть жонглювати
ними
із серії якщо ми підкинемо їм ще один
Можливо вони розгублять усі м'ячі і ми
зможемо отримати вигоду з ситуації
і ми бачимо як Виникають нові конфлікти
чи можливо зони конфлікту щодо Косово та
Сербії чи щодо Вірменії та Азербайджану
чому саме зараз ми бачимо всі ці спалахи
в основному тому що підкидається новий
м'яч і очікується Що з ним буде дуже
складно впоратися тож Європейський Союз
має бути готовим до такого
повертаючись до війни Росії проти
України а якщо до санкцій чи є в
арсеналі Європейського Союзу нові
санкції
Якщо так то що на вашу думку потрібно
зробити
Я думаю що апетит щодо додаткових
санкцій вичерпався
багато європейських країн із тривогу
дивляться на майбутню зиму адже йдеться
про ціни на газ та енергоносії
коли я вважаю що все буде не так погано
Як очікується
завжди краще очікувати найгіршого і бути
готовим до ситуації яка може виявитися
не дуже гарною а потім мати інструменти
для вирішення майбутніх проблем
Але я думаю що в основному все буде не
так погано
Я сподіваюся що ми зможемо повернутися
до посилення тиску на Росію
коли побачимо що Європа може впоратися і
ситуацію довкола енергоносіїв
чи не боїтеся Ви що ця енергетична криза
що насувається призведе до нових
закликів до миру в лапках чи без ви
згадували про це ця війна результат
цього конфлікту вирішуватиметься на полі
бою але є багато людей в інших
європейських столицях дуже великих які
вважають що зрештою треба домовлятися
про мир Як ви вважаєте чи це буде новою
пропозицією через енергетичну кризу
взимку і серії давайте залучимо Путіна
Ну побачимо є багато речей які
відрізняють нас від сьогоднішньої Росії
це демократія яка є у Європі це означає
що уряди змінюються приходять нові сили
партії та розпочинають нову політику і
вони можуть бачити ситуацію інакше
я вважаю що нинішня картина
європейського континенту та 27
європейських країн є досить стабільною
хоча думки і розходяться
не бачу серйозних змін у політичній
позиції коли йдеться про процеси в Росії
це означає що відповідає чи на ваше
запитання Я не вірю що якийсь із
нинішніх урядів наполегливо проситиме
про мир і з Росією
але уряди змінюються
нові Чи старі партії можуть мати якісь
свої пропозиції
але ви проти них ви взагалі проти розмов
із Путіним абсолютно Я маю на увазі коли
країни визнають що відбувається
і ми визнаємо що це сталося Не без
політичної згодою чи фактично зі
схвалення і можливо навіть із заохочення
політичної еліти у Москві Я не вірю що
це можливо що це було б хоча б якоюсь
мірою нормально
якщо ми вже заговорили про санкції чи
мають вони шкодити в цьому російському
населенню
вони шкодить усьому населенню Росії
на жаль це лише так працює
інтерв'ю розпочалося з розмови про
заборони видачі віз з метою туризму
Так на жаль росіяни будуть змушені
обмежити свої відпустки будуть обмежені
в речах які вони можуть придбати Я думаю
що особливо у великих містах Росії
існував середній клас що формувався Який
звик до того що можна назвати західним
способом життя
Я думаю що тепер із цим покінчено
це дуже невеликий сегмент російського
населення Ну я не вірю що в Москві Це
дуже маленький сегмент Так але з іншого
боку є аргумент і він не стосується
виключно даної ситуації це
обговорювалося щоразу коли вводилися
санкції проти будь-якої країни якщо
ввести дуже жорсткі санкції то населення
зазвичай схильне консолідуватися навколо
режиму згуртуватися навколо лідера у
цьому випадку згуртуватися навколо
Путіна Ви побоюєтеся цього
Я гадаю що ми бачимо що це вже
відбувається
опитуванням які ми бачимо Хто знає що
насправді відповідають люди хто знає яке
питання поставили соціологи
тому важко їм вірити
Але я вважаю що ми бачимо деякі
тенденції ми бачимо що є довіра до
сильного лідера яка була завжди
особливо після дії російських військ у
2008-му та 2014 роках Ми спостерігали
зростання довіри до Путіна
тому я не дуже здивований що ми бачимо
щось подібне і зараз Але знову ж таки
якщо повернутися до початку
Росія велика країна тому навіть якщо є
10% населення
які налаштовані категорично проти це
дуже багато людей
питання чи зможуть вони висловити свій
протест так мабуть зараз це дуже важко
для них Але я вірю що час настане
зовсім недавно власне цього літа ЄС
скасував принаймні частину своєї
політики щодо транзиту з материкової
Росії до російського як склаву
калінінградської області на Балтійському
морі
Литва хотіла по суті заблокувати весь
транзит із Росії до Калінінграда ЄС
сказав ні
чи вважаєте ви що це ознака слабкості чи
почувається Литва зрадженою брюсселем Ні
я вважаю що насамперед Литва хотіла щоб
Брюссель зберіг свою початкову позицію і
ми вважаємо що це було справедливо але
ми вважаємо що і Росія має причини щоб
доставляти товари в Калінінград ви
знаєте що це в жодному разі не повинно
бути європейським питанням це російське
питання це не європейська проблема
У будь-якому разі після довгих роздумів
Рішення було змінено
і у нинішньому вигляді існує система
квот де Європа встановила обмеження
яка кількість товарів першою
необхідності вугілля деревини
необхідному Калінінграді
і саме ця кількість може бути переміщена
через територію ЄС
інформація
на мій погляд це не ідеально але це
компроміс на який ми пішли із цим можна
працювати
був у розлючений коли Литва спробувала
заблокувати транзит до Калінінграда
якщо ви подивитеся російське телебачення
Він все ще лютує
А ви відчуваєте що Путін немає свої
плани на Литву Литовську територію та її
суверенітет і чи вірити Ви що НАТО
захистить її
ну по-перше російська пропаганда
намагалася подати це як рішення Литви
це важко в тлумачити російський
пропаганді
але я міг би скористатися цією
можливістю щоб пояснити хоча б людям які
дивляться нашу розмову що це було
європейське рішення яке реалізувало
Литва
тож можливо Росія мала бути задоволена
європейським рішенням але як ви
розумієте завжди доводиться махати
кулаками на тих хто менший наприклад на
Литву це типова поведінка хулігана
знаходились
Ми не боїмося Росії ми вважаємо що НАТО
є найсильнішим і найдієздатнішим
альянсом який коли-небудь існував
ми дуже раді дізнатися що наші сусіди в
Естонії
придбають наступного року ракети на суму
500 мільйонів євро
Сподіваюся ми наслідуватимемо їхні кроки
Я вважаю що це те що має у нас відбутися
ми повинні озброюватися
і Ми продовжуємо це робити це має стати
посланням
що ми не та територія куди російські
війська можуть увійти за наказом Путіна
Як довго ви думаєте триватиметься війна
я знаю ви сказали що це залежить від
українців але це також залежить від
багатьох інших чинників ваше припущення
як довго Європі ще доведеться жити із
цією війною
на це питання відповісти складно
тут справа стосується воєнних стратегій
можу сказати вам що я твердо впевнений
захід має усі засоби щоб допомогти
українцям покінчити з цією війною дуже
швидко
дякую